DOM JOLY: OK, but--
MALE SPEAKER: So please welcome
with a round of applause,
from there to here, Dom Joly.
DOM JOLY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Are we sitting on these?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I am.
DOM JOLY: How to make me
more uncomfortable and weird.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: They're not the
most comfortable of chairs,
but--
DOM JOLY: I would just
like to say I'm over 30,
and I seem to be the only person
in this entire building that
is.
You just get an
email when you're 30,
just hopefully-- you're right.
Oh, thank god.
Yeah, dial up.
Remember dial up?
Amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: It's
[INAUDIBLE] "Logan's Run."
Do you want to talk
about yourself, the book,
where the book's come from?
DOM JOLY: Whatever you want
me to talk about, really.
MALE SPEAKER: With why
the book and why now?
DOM JOLY: Why the book, why now?
Well, for someone that's
said-- and I really meant it--
I didn't think anyone should
write an autobiography
till you're I think at least
60 and definitely, like,
you've finished.
I've now done two.
But in my defense, the first
one was in 2004, straight
after "Trigger Happy."
And someone approached
me and said,
would you like to
write an autobiography?
And I said, absolutely no way.
No way.
And then they told me what
the advance was going to be,
and I went, yeah, OK.
Possibly.
And actually, weirdly, I
had this exact same thing
with Lily Allen once.
I'm going to name
drop straight away.
I was doing this reality
show where I was a paparazzi.
And I'd spent two weeks
completely forgetting who I was
and just chasing
celebs and being
hit around the head with stuff.
And on the last
night, I'd finished.
And I just got Lily Allen.
I went back to a bar in
SoHo and I was relaxing.
And Lily Allen walks in.
And I'm like, fuck, I'm
still-- and I thought, no.
I'm not paparazzi mode anymore.
And she makes a beeline
for me, and she sits down.
She's chatting away.
And I'm trying to
pretend it's really cool.
But this is when she
was at her coolest.
And I'm just going,
yeah, just sitting here
with Lily Allen, totally cool.
And she's moaning away.
She's going, oh, you know,
all this stuff's going on.
And now they've asked
me to write a book.
And I think, maybe
this is the time for me
to step in as an elder
man of show business.
I said, Lily, you know
if you want my advice,
you're topping the charts.
You're really cool
at the moment.
Don't stretch yourself too
wide by doing a book as well.
Why would you?
And she goes, well, they've
offered me $800,000.
And I'm like, OK, yeah,
maybe do the book.
But actually, as
it turned out, she
had to hand the advance
back because she
didn't manage to do the book.
So though you go.
So I have written it.
And I have like weirdly a lot
of people-- I'm quite surprised.
I'm not going to name
names-- Russell Brand--
but how many people that you
do assume would be smart enough
to write their own book
actually don't write it.
I mean, I'm sure they
have an input in it,
some more than others.
But it's weird.
There are a lot
of ghost writers.
But I did actually
write my book myself.
MALE SPEAKER: What I
got from your book--
DOM JOLY: Was deep unhappiness.
MALE SPEAKER: No, no.
It's when you did
"Trigger Happy TV"--
DOM JOLY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: --which you're
probably best known for still.
DOM JOLY: Yeah, thanks, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot of the--
[LAUGHTER]
I mean--
DOM JOLY: Yeah,
no, no, it's fine.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot of it
was found in the edits.
DOM JOLY: Yeah, oh, absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
wondered with the book,
was it the same process?
Did you write a
lot and edit down?
DOM JOLY: No, it's really weird.
I'm the world's most--
one of the reasons
I've had such an odd career
in all sorts of ways, ups
and down, is I'm
so easily bored.
And I can't really
stick to anything.
And actually the only
thing I've ever really put
just total focus in was
"Trigger Happy," weirdly,
and it was kind of when
there was no pressure.
I didn't know "Trigger
Happy" was going to be huge.
It was the first
comedy show I'd done.
It was literally
like I'd suddenly
got in a situation where
me and my new best friend,
Sam, who I made it with,
who I met in a bar, as I
was telling my girlfriend
that I had the opportunity
to make this show, but I
couldn't afford a cameraman.
And literally Sam was the
barman, leaned over and goes,
I can do that.
Nobody believes the story,
but that is how we met.
So we did "Trigger
Happy," really
thinking we're still excited
we're going to be on telly.
And everyone left us alone.
We spent a year.
We basically had
fun, all the things
that afterwards came when
advertising agencies would
ring us up and offer stupid
money if we did an ad
in the "Trigger Happy" style.
And we'd nod going,
well, it's quite tricky.
The "Trigger Happy" style
was just me making Sam laugh,
and he'd shake the
camera, and that was it.
[LAUGHTER]
But essentially "Trigger
Happy," I think,
is a pretty good
hidden camera show.
But I think where it
really differentiated
was when we went into the edit.
And I'm kind of a
frustrated musician.
I love music.
I was in a band, but sadly
have no musical talent.
But I've always loved
loads and loads of music.
It was never like thought
through like this.
But when I go into
the edit, it just
made sense to me to
put my favorite moments
of my favorite
tracks over stuff.
And I remember the first
time we gave something in.
It was the dogs, fighting dogs.
We used to have two dogs that
used to beat each other up.
Like a lot of other
things in "Trigger Happy,"
that started with a vague point.
We used to walk
through-- around here,
actually, because we were
based on Charing Cross Road.
And it was when all the CCTV
cameras just started going up.
And you used to see all
these things and think, well,
who watches these cameras?
Who's just monitoring it?
So it just made us laugh to
have the idea of setting up
two dogs, one tied to a chair,
and there's an execution scene.
And we just love the idea
that somewhere in some bank
someone's spooning through, it's
like, what the fuck was that?
[LAUGHTER]
So they used to start on
a camera and swoop down.
But after a moment we just
thought, it doesn't matter.
Just do that.
And the first time
we gave it in,
I had some weird U2
opera tune on it.
It was all quite weird,
because you think,
this is quite moving.
But actually, it's just a dog.
And someone at Channel
4 said, don't you
think you should put
some cartoon music on it?
And I was just like, oh my
god, you so don't get this.
So to answer the
question a long way,
yes, we spent a long
time in the edit.
And I think a lot of
it was about the music.
Music was incredibly
expensive to clear abroad.
The only place that bought
the entire soundtrack
was Germany, weirdly.
And I didn't sell it
to America for ages,
because if it went
to America, it
had to go with a
terrible sound alike.
So all these great songs I'd
chosen, someone in his basement
just did sort of literally
like a homemade version of it.
And it was just
like, oh, I can't.
But in the end, I gave up.
And it did get to
the States like that.
So yeah, the edit was what
it was all about, really.
And I think people don't
appreciate that, really,
because I think
in a funny sense,
if you took all the
music off, you've
got a reasonably funny
hidden camera show
where the punchline is either
me running away or telling
someone I've had a
shattering nervous breakdown.
But I think the music gave
it unwarranted depth, maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: There were
three soundtracks, three CDs.
DOM JOLY: There were three
CDs, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, that was
the coolest thing.
I got a gold record
for the soundtracks.
And I've never felt
more of a fraud.
Because part of me is
like, that's the dream.
When I grew up, I didn't
dream of being a comedian.
I sort of, I suppose,
dreamt of being a rock star.
And suddenly I've got
my own gold record.
But what's it for?
It's a bit like being a DJ.
I'm sorry, I don't see
the skill in being a DJ.
You're playing someone
else's records.
I mean, that's it.
So maybe you can
choose good ones,
but then to be
given a gold disk.
Oh, that was me, actually.
It was great.
The best music story about it
was probably the most requested
song-- because a lot of
people commented on the songs.
And we even had a
couple of bands--
there was one called
the Honey Smugglers who
are the most obscure band.
And I don't know how I
heard their one song.
But after I put it
on "Trigger Happy,"
they got back together,
which was quite exciting.
They lasted three months
and then broke up again.
But the most requested
tune was Gordon Lightfoot,
"If You Can Read My Mind."
And that was on
this mad portrait
artist in [INAUDIBLE] Square.
And I hadn't heard
of Gordon Lightfoot.
But now I'm married
to a Canadian.
And I know that he's probably
the most famous Canadian apart
from Celine Dion,
and that song has
been covered by so many people.
But at the time, I didn't know.
And we kept getting these
requests, what is this song?
And someone said, you
know what-- again, it
was me trying to be a
pop star-- why don't we
get hold of Gordon Lightfoot?
He's probably living
in some, you know, log
cabin in the middle of nowhere.
And we'll tell him it's
a big hit in England,
and we could make a video like
Vic Reeves did with "Dizzy,"
and we'd get the
[INAUDIBLE] number one.
I was so excited.
So we contacted his
people, sent the request.
Nothing came back,
nothing came back.
Finally I rang up,
and they said, well,
can we see the show?
So we sent them the show.
Time tick, nothing came out.
So finally I'm
like, fuck's sake.
So I had a vision of someone
running up a long path
to Gordon saying,
Gordon, Gordon,
you're going to be back.
So finally I ring
up and go, look,
is this going to happen or not?
And they go, afraid it's a no.
And said, well, why?
And he said, Gordon
saw the show,
and well, he just
thought it was shit.
[LAUGHTER]
So there you go, Gordon
Lightfoot-- wanker.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: With
the later series,
you seemed to
thrive under having
less control from the powers
that be, and so forth.
DOM JOLY: I think all
telly, and probably
all business in a funny way,
must thrive from-- well,
I don't know.
It's an odd thing.
I think when you have a
certain level of-- I don't
know how to explain it, really.
The odd thing to me is when
"Trigger Happy" was unknown
and it wasn't a hit at all, we
were totally left on our own.
And I think certainly
in comedy, when
people say, as they often do
on Twitter, "you're not funny,"
I'm like, well, that's a
very subjective thing to say.
Because if I find it
funny, then it is funny.
It's just you don't
find it funny.
But the one thing that
definitely isn't funny
is if 10 people get together
and decide what's funny.
You end up with the
equivalent of the Eurostar
interior decoration where
someone just thought,
you know what,
yellow and gray is
going to offend the
least amount of people.
So to me in comedy,
even if you're
doing something that's literally
everyone saying is awful,
if you find it funny,
that's all you can do.
The moment you try and guess
what other people find funny
or listen to a
committee, you're fucked.
And the irony of telly is
that "Trigger Happy," no one
knew who we were, so we
totally were left alone, even
into the edit and everything.
And then the moment it was a
hit, logic should tell you,
well, it ain't broke, fix it.
Because everyone then jumps in.
Because they want
to be part of it.
And it instantly
goes to pot, really.
MALE SPEAKER: Because it
was, when it launched,
sandwiched between "Friends"
and "Frasier" on Channel 4.
DOM JOLY: It was insane.
I'd never been on
telly apart from,
I'd done some stuff on the
Paramount Comedy Channel, which
was this weird channel
that only played sort
of imported American shows.
But when I was there, it
was just a really odd time.
For two years, there were all
these people doing little shows
that we'd put out
between the programs.
They were called interstitials.
And in telly, normally you
never get the opportunity
to practice.
Literally, you're either a
stand up or someone else,
and you become well known, and
then your first thing you do
is on telly.
And that's a very tricky thing.
Whereas if you're
a stand up, you
spend years honing
your craft and stuff.
But for some reason,
we all got lucky.
We were paid nothing.
But at that time at Paramount
Comedy Channel, which
is just up the road
in [INAUDIBLE] Place,
Sasha Baron Cohen was
doing some early Borat,
as it turned out then.
Lee Francis is in
the art department.
Little Britain were wandering
around doing a weird show
called "Mash and Peas."
Simon Peg was doing an odd
show with Edgar Wright.
I mean, it was crazy.
And I was looking at all
these people thinking--
it was almost like a bit
of a "Saturday Night Live"
sort of thing.
Except they've all gone on to
do incredibly well in comedy,
apart from me, and
I've written this book.
But no, it was good.
I can't remember the question.
MALE SPEAKER: How did you
cope with that level of fame?
DOM JOLY: Very badly.
Very badly in all sorts of ways.
And I think I only
didn't understand why,
because it's not like
I want to be famous.
Because I'm not
interested in fame.
But I definitely want
to be successful,
because it allows you to do
these things you're enjoying.
And weirdly, I just
read an interview
with Louis Theroux who kind
of disappeared as well.
He was getting big at the
same time as "Trigger Happy"
with weird weekends.
And he went off to LA.
And I never quite
understood why.
And he said he went from making
these documentaries that he
really enjoyed, and
also an important part
was that people didn't really
know who Louis Theroux was.
The moment you kind of felt,
is he going to stitch you up,
it would've been more difficult.
And he said, suddenly
he went from making
shows he was really
interested in
that people liked to suddenly
being constantly told, oh,
is he going to be
able to do it again?
Like, are you going
to get the ratings?
And I suppose that's
just show biz, really.
But it's deeply unpleasant.
because then you start, A,
getting worried, so you start
making bad decisions, I think.
And then in the end, you
either go completely against it
and say, fuck you, and
everyone hates you,
or you completely toe the
line and make appalling stuff.
And I think I've
done both, actually.
I've done the full
gamut, you know.
MALE SPEAKER: And when you
were making "Trigger Happy TV,"
the book said you got arrested
a fair bit, or throughout.
Youve not been beaten up.
DOM JOLY: No, weirdly.
I mean, think, I'm the
first person getting beaten.
I have this really odd ability
to get people to the stage
where they want to beat you up.
Although, in my defense, my
comedy is not [INAUDIBLE].
It's really easy to
get people angry.
You just find out what they
love-- their car, their garden,
and just turn up.
And now it's the
council's turned
your garden into a public loo.
Step back.
They all get mental.
I didn't want to
make people angry.
My whole thing,
almost, it was annoying
that people had to
sign afterwards,
and you let them
know, which we did.
Because I kind of love
the idea of just inserting
this surreal moment
into someone's day.
So in my mind, I always
loved someone coming home
and the wife saying,
how was your day today?
And he goes, yeah, it was good.
It was good-- a bit weird.
I was in the park, and
a scout approached me
and asked me to mark him out of
10 for his homoerotic dancing
badge.
And I love that.
It was the idea that this
weird world is going on.
And if I had to admit,
the person I probably
nick most ideas
from, I don't know
if anyone knows the cartoons
by Gary Larson called
"The Far Side," which you're
all too young, probably.
But it was amazing.
Yeah, thank you.
You know.
And he was all about things
like a bunch of sheep
in a field, chatting
aways and smoking.
And one of them shouts,
"car!" and they all
go back down, sort of thing.
And so I love that kind of
odd, slightly surreal humor.
But then again, I think
when your success,
you even start
believing yourself
that you meant more than that.
Because analyzing
comedy is terrible.
All I want to do is be funny.
And there was a scene--
a terrible one, actually,
it wasn't even funny-- where
I'm a Chelsea pensioner pushing
a pram down the steps.
Really not funny, looking back.
And if anything, it
was a sort of mild piss
take of that scene in
the-- what's the movie?
AUDIENCE: "Untouchables."
DOM JOLY: "Untouchables,"
thank you very much.
But "The Guardian"
reviewed it saying,
incredibly brave reworking
of Eisenstein's "Potemkin."
And I'm like--
[LAUGHTER]
You know, which
was a famous scene
on the steps in
"Russian Revolution."
So I was like, of course.
That's exactly what I meant.
So yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And well, from
filming "Trigger Happy," three
seasons, were there?
DOM JOLY: There were two
seasons of six shows eat.
And then I wanted to, again,
this is my first huge career
mistake.
The one thing I've
learned is never ever--
MALE SPEAKER: There's a table.
DOM JOLY: Never
make any decision
that's important straight
after you've just
finished doing something.
And I'm sure that
applies in anything else.
Because you're sick
to death of it.
You're knackered.
You're disillusioned.
You probably hate
everyone you're with.
So the moment you finish that,
that is not the moment to say,
ooh, I'm not going to do
another "Trigger Happy," which
is what I told Channel 4.
What you need to
do is say, I'd like
to do some vanity projects
for a couple of years,
and I'll give you a "Trigger
Happy" every two years
when I'm refreshed.
As it was, I treated it a
bit like a band, really.
I was like, right.
We've made our great album.
Now let's leave.
I'm never going to do it again.
And then Channel 4
said, will you at least
do two Christmas specials?
And I said, naw.
And then they offered me
a stupid amount of money.
I went, yeah, yeah, OK, I will.
And they were
actually quite good.
But then we kind of fell out.
I fell out with Channel 4.
It was quite odd.
And just as I was
wondering what to do,
I got a call from the pope, or
Alan Yentob, as we call him,
who's this weird head of the
BBC who literally pillages
the modern art galleries
to put in his-- I mean,
he's like a sort of war
lord at the top of the BBC.
And he took me to
the River Cafe.
And I wasn't quite sure
what I was doing there,
and he took a call halfway
through. (WHISPERS) Sorry.
Mick Jagger.
And I was like, what?
Who is this guy?
And I slowly realized he
was luring me to the BBC.
And A, I thought,
well, that's good,
because I can go somewhere
else and start again.
And he kept saying, the thing
about the BBC is we're public.
We're paid for by the
people, by the license fee.
There's no ads.
So we're not
interested in ratings.
There'll be no pressure.
We just want you
to make whatever
it is you want to make.
I thought, that
sounds brilliant.
The moment I got to
the BBC, I realized
that was total bollocks.
I mean they're so obsessed with
ratings that I got terrified.
But on top of that, when
you work for the BBC,
things change.
On my second day at the
Beeb, I got given an office.
And I'm sitting there
thinking, I've got an office.
This is so exciting.
And a guy comes
in looking almost
like one of the two
Ronnies, like a BBC workman.
And he goes, Mr. Joly,
everyone who gets
a new office gets it decorated.
So I just wanted to know what
color you'd like it painted.
I'm like, I hadn't
even thought about it.
He goes, well, we're
going to paint.
So what color would you like?
And I went, red.
So he goes, all right,
and off he went.
Two days later in the
mirror, huge page saying,
"Trigger Happy" star has
tantrum, refuses to start-- no,
sees red, refuses to
start work at the BBC
until his suite of
offices are painted red.
And I'm like, fucking hell.
So I suddenly realized that
we weren't little punky people
on the outside.
And suddenly you're
on your pedestal,
and the only way was down.
And that's terrifying,
especially when
I'm just much happier being
a sort of little irritant,
really, on the side.
I'm much happier doing
that, which luckily is
what I've come back to being.
MALE SPEAKER: What's the
most outlandish thing
a tabloid has lied about?
DOM JOLY: Well, my
favorite one was
I found out-- I'm sort of
quite estranged from a lot
of my family, which
I went buoy with.
But I've got quite
an odd family.
And my sister I hadn't spoken
to for about eight years.
She lives in Lebanon.
And my dad and I
sort of barely spoke.
And he lived in France.
And suddenly I get
two calls from them,
which was rare enough.
And my sister said,
just to let you know--
this is just as "Trigger
Happy" is happening--
someone from "The Daily
Mail"-- and this is in Beirut,
in the middle of the war.
I'm like, fucking hell,
how'd he get there?
He was knocking on
the door, trying
to ask questions about
you, because they were
doing a piece on my background.
She goes, I'm not sure
if I helped you or not,
but I set the dogs on them.
I was like, fucking brilliant.
That's great.
And then my dad, a
man who literally I've
had probably four
conversations within 10 years,
all about cricket,
rings me up, out
of the blue, very
awkward conversation.
And he says-- and obviously
he's feeling a bit
guilty about our relationship.
He said, a man, very nice
man, from "The Daily Mail"
turned up at the door,
asking about you.
So I hope you don't
mind, I let him in.
And I was like, what?
And then I gave him a
couple of photos as well.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
So when the expose
came out, I was like,
what are they going to do?
And it literally
said, exclusive,
"Trigger Happy" star
is middle class.
I was like, OK, if that's
the best you can do.
But then they had two pictures
my dad had given of one of me
on a pony and one of me naked.
It was about when I was
about four years old.
It was like, oh.
So I've been all
right with tabloids.
I've kind of kept away
from them, really.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and do
you think that you seeking out
new challenges and being
an irritant, as you say,
do you think that led
you to be-- you've
done a fair number of those
"I'm a Celeb" and "Splash!"
and so forth.
Is that the reason you chose
those, or just the challenge?
DOM JOLY: Well, I think
there's two things.
One thing the book kind
of talks about is my life
makes total sense to me.
Because I think most
people when they're,
for instance, like a hidden
camera comedian in England,
hidden camera is seen
really as a bit rubbish.
And most of it is rubbish.
It's just people shouting.
It's a bit crap.
In America, because hidden
camera-- a lot of people
don't realize, it
is all improvised.
There's no scripts.
When I go up to someone,
I'm making it up as I go.
And that's quite a skill.
But in England,
there's nowhere to go
with that really apart
from that awful show,
was it "Whose Line
is it Anyway,"
which always ended up with
John Sessions pretending
he was in a lift.
In America, people who
do this sort of thing
move on to do things
like "Curb Your
Enthusiasm," "Spinal
Tap," which is
all sort of improv and comedy.
And it's kind of
quite respected.
So here, if you
look at "Fonejacker"
or if you look at Ali
G, what you really do
is you make your
name doing that.
And then you become an actor.
And I have no interest
in becoming an actor.
My only skill is
making up my own stuff.
I don't want to spout
someone else's stuff.
So for me, when "Trigger Happy"
happened, I thought, great.
This allows me to write for
newspapers, go travel writing,
and write travel
books, which I've done.
I've written books and
gone skiing in Iran
and weekended in Chernobyl,
and gone to North Korea.
But the problem is
that the sort of people
who like "Trigger Happy"-- I
don't want to say this exactly,
but not great readers,
maybe, let's say.
And the people who
love travel books
are possibly not the greatest
fans of hidden cameras.
So I've got these
two odd fan bases,
that if they met in a room
would hate each other probably.
And one side might actually
beat the other side up.
So it's quite odd to do.
So when I did comedy,
it would pay the bills.
And then I'd go and
do what I wanted,
which is travel writing,
which, let me tell you,
does not pay anything.
I mean, you basically
fund your own travel,
but the good thing is someone
will read about it afterwards.
That's the only good thing.
And then when comedy
stopped for a bit,
the reality shows
were, literally,
another way of just
paying the mortgage
so I could go traveling.
"I'm a Celeb," I kind
of was in so two minds.
They ask everyone every year.
As far as I can
see, "I'm a Celeb"
has a list of 3,000 celebs.
And every year, they send out
this mass email that goes,
we'd love you to be
on "I'm a Celeb."
And depending on the
state of your career,
certain people say yes.
And then once they've got the
pool of people who said yes,
they cast it.
So they'd asked me for about
eight years, and I'd said no,
despite loving the show.
And then just as they asked me
that year, I suddenly thought,
A, hmm.
I need a bit of money.
B, I genuinely thought,
actually, it might suit me.
Because it's one of the few
places-- one of the people
who was in there with
me was Jenny Eclair,
who I really loved.
I don't know many comedians,
but Jenny weirdly, was
quite frightened in
there, because she's
used to doing stand up.
She's got a routine.
She controls her comedy.
So she was always
worried when we
were set a task, because
she's not good at improv.
Whereas for me, it was a joy.
They told me to be a
spy and lie to the camp
and pretend to speak Korean.
I'm like, hello.
This is exactly
what it should be.
So yeah, that's why
I did those shows.
The only one I do
regret is "Splash!"
If I have to talk
about it, the reason
I did "Splash!"-- A,
"Splash!" hadn't gone out.
So the way these
shows are sold to you
is always very different
from how they are.
MALE SPEAKER: Training
with Tom Daley.
DOM JOLY: It was sold
to me as, would you
like to learn an Olympic skill,
high diving in particular.
And I weirdly have a bit of
a back history in diving.
I get a calendar
every year of my kids.
We jump off these cliffs.
And I'm pretty good
at jumping off.
But there are always these
annoying 15-year-olds
who turn up and do a flip.
And in the back of my mind
I thought, just before I
get too old, I'd love to just
have one dive that kind of
shows them up a bit.
So they go, Tom Daley's
going to teach you.
I'm like, well, it's brilliant.
What could go wrong?
It was, A, it was ripoff.
Tom Daley turned
up probably twice
for about 10 minutes, filmed
going, mmm, that's good,
and then disappeared.
Secondly, what I
didn't realize was
the show was designed as a sort
of homoerotic TOWIE spin off.
And the first guest was
when we had a costume thing.
I go, what do you mean, costume?
I'm not wearing
Speedos, but we're
going to be wearing swim trunks.
They go, oh no.
And it was all
tassels and stuff.
And I was like, oh my god.
Then Joey Essex turned
up, and I met him.
And I just couldn't understand
if he was real or not.
First two times I
met him, genuinely,
he was locked in the loo
and couldn't get out.
And I had to release him.
Genuinely.
And I thought he's either
the greatest improv comedian
that exists or he's so stupid.
It's like, how did he
get here sort of thing.
And then come the night, I
was actually doing quite well.
In rehearsal, I was
the first person
to go off the 10 meter board,
which is seriously frightening.
And I thought, you know
what, I'll be all right.
My kids come along.
It's probably the first thing
my kids have come to, my wife.
It's all there.
It's live.
And I get so nervous
beforehand that me
and [INAUDIBLE] consume a
whole bottle of champagne.
I'm totally pissed.
Adrenaline hits me so badly.
I go out, and they announce your
name, and I'm like in a dream.
I go to the top, and I just
think, get over the dive.
And Vernon Kay's up there
going, so, Dom, how you feeling?
I'm like, I don't
fucking-- I don't--
And everything I'd learned went.
And I just jumped.
And I literally
went in slow motion.
I felt myself go over.
And I thought, fuck, this is it.
I'm going to land on my back.
I'm either going to die or
be paralyzed, live on air,
in a homoerotic reality show
in front of my children.
And I hit the water.
It hurt like nothing
I can describe.
And I came up.
And I was sort of like that.
There wasn't even a
murmur from the crowd.
It wasn't even sympathy.
It was just like, fucking hell.
And I was just like that.
And all I can see was my
daughter who's just, oh shit.
So that was probably the lowest
moment in my career, yeah.
But the joy of doing what
I do, becasue I write,
is even then I
thinking, actually, this
will be funny to write about.
And I suppose that's
the one good thing.
If I travel write, obviously
I'd love to go somewhere
and it's brilliant, and I
stay in an amazing hotel,
and everyone's lovely,
and I have a nice holiday.
But if, like everyone,
and you go on a trip
and it turns into a nightmare,
I'm always thinking,
well, actually, this is
going to be a lot funnier
to write about.
So always part of me is
thinking, things go wrong,
I can use it.
MALE SPEAKER: From
the travel writing,
what was your biggest
blag you reckon?
And we'll take some questions.
DOM JOLY: Holy fuck, my life--
all travel writing is blag.
It's insane, because
travel writing
pays zero money because
they basically say, look.
We'll probably be able
to organize a free hotel,
sometimes a free flight.
So what, you want
to be paid as well?
And you're like,
well, kind of, yeah.
So there's two types
of travel writing.
There's what I call the
Piers Morgan travel writing,
"Mail on Sunday," where Piers
Morgan takes his wife and two
kids to Lamborghini
world in Dubai,
which is just the
sort of place he'd go.
Hello, Piers.
And all is paid.
He insists on first class there.
He wanders around
Lamborghini world.
He stays in the
hotel for two nights,
comes back, writes literally
an article saying, my kids
and I went to Lamborghini world.
We drove Lamborghinis.
It was amazing.
And that's it.
And then there's
proper travel writing,
which to me is about going
somewhere off the beaten track,
trying to really get
an adventure, which
is more and more hard.
Because nowadays, it's
very difficult anywhere
where you're not 100
meters from a Starbucks,
even if you're in
Libya or wherever.
So things like North Korea--
but in fact, the only place
you can really
go, unfortunately,
are places that are either
in the middle of a civil war
or under a horrible
dictatorship.
So you have this odd,
should I go there or not?
And that's proper
travel writing.
And in the old days,
people like "Sunday Times"
would pay for that.
But now more and more it's all
about advertising, weirdly.
Because Google, I think,
says the algorithms--
they're all trying to
drive you to their website.
And they don't want
this sort of thing.
So now travel writing
in "Sunday Times"
is lists of world's
top 10 beaches
and best honeymoon things.
And that's probably
Google's fault, or Buzzfeed.
MALE SPEAKER: On
that, does anyone
have any questions [INAUDIBLE]?
We've got a mic in the back.
DOM JOLY: Well, I can
hear you probably.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
your thoughts on a show
like "Revolution Will Be
Televised," [INAUDIBLE],
hidden camera,
[INAUDIBLE], family show.
It's kind of a similar
point where you left off.
It's on a couple of
shows here, you know,
that will recognize
and [INAUDIBLE]
is kind of an extension
strategy, I guess.
Do you think it's
the end for them?
DOM JOLY: See, I should
never slag off comedy,
but I'm going to.
I hate that show.
And I'll tell you why I hate it.
I started off, the first job I
got on "The Mark Thomas Comedy
Product," which was basically an
English version of the "Michael
Moore Show" before
Michael Moore.
And Mark is a stand
up who you might know.
He's a bit of a
political activist.
And he can get a bit
annoying occasionally
with his militant setting.
But the idea at
the time was good.
It was like, let's take on MPs
and set them up and do stunts.
And I think that
was the first one.
And I was the
research on that show,
and that's where I started off.
And then when I was doing early
stuff for "Trigger Happy,"
I took that on. and I was
attacking Cool Britannia
and putting fake
Millennium Domes
in Peter Mandelson's
garden and standing
as a teddy bear and stuff.
And it was kind of
odd surreal activism.
And when we went to Channel
4 to pitch for the show,
I was actually
pitching show which
was about taking
on Cool Britannia,
and it was kind of a
bit like that show.
And the commissioning
editor had just
finished doing Chris
Morris's "Brass Eye," which
literally she'd been in nothing
but legal battles for a year.
And she just went, ah,
fuck, not another one.
She said, please.
If you can do anything
that wasn't socially based,
so she said, can you
do something silly?
And that's how "Trigger
Happy" happened.
With "The Revolution
That Must Be Televised,"
my problem with it,
genuinely, is that I just
don't think it's that funny.
And I think you either
have to do something
where you're being funny,
and if you make a point,
it's kind of as a side thing.
Or you have to literally
be, I'm a hardcore whatever.
And I think they're
not that political,
but they're not that funny.
And so they end up
kind of just shoving
microphones in their face.
But then maybe I'm just old and
I don't know comedy anymore.
I don't know.
I love the name of the show.
And I kind of
think, yeah, you're
exactly what I was, an annoying
little posh bloke 20 years ago.
So probably that's
why I don't like it,
because they're on
telly and I'm not.
And they won a BAFTA.
So did "Fonejacker."
I didn't win a BAFTA,
so yeah, that's why.
But good luck to them.
And the other thing
they do-- sorry--
when they go to America,
what I've realized, again,
is the classic way all shows go.
You do two shows.
Your second show's probably
a bit more successful.
And then the third show, it's
called the "On the Buses"
Spanish holiday thing.
You suddenly think, fuck,
we can get people to come.
So I started seeing if
I could get madness.
You get cameos.
And then once you've got all the
cameos of the people you want--
so Ricky Gervais did it well
with "Extras"-- you then think,
where can we go on holiday?
We should go to do
an American show.
And they very rarely
work when you go abroad.
So I didn't answer anything
there, but there you go.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
It's good to hear
your opinion on it.
Appreciate it.
DOM JOLY: I'm really sorry
if you are watching this.
I hate slagging off
other comedians.
I'm not slagging him off.
It's just whatever.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen
much of YouTube videos,
because prank videos are
quite big on YouTube,
and I wonder if
you've seen them,
or what "Trigger Happy" would've
been like if you'd done it now.
DOM JOLY: Two things, really,
the reason "Trigger Happy"
happened was because it
was just at that year
where cameras became
available in the shops.
They were called
three chip cameras,
which now when you look at
the quality, it's awful.
But it was the first
time that for a grand
you could buy a
camera which you could
use which was, at the time,
good enough to go on telly.
A year before that, if you
wanted to film anything,
you had to hire a proper
cameramen, proper sound man.
Nothing wrong with that,
but they cost money.
So it meant you only had
a limited amount of time.
And suddenly we
bought that camera,
and we just filmed
and filmed, because it
wasn't costing any money.
So that was huge.
But if YouTube
had existed then--
and it came probably
five years afterwards-- I
wouldn't have bothered
going to TV channels.
Why would I go to a
TV channel and say,
can I give you 90% of my
earnings to put it out?
I would have set up
a YouTube channel.
And if it worked well enough,
worked out some sort of deal--
I don't know how you pay
them-- but there you go.
So yeah, I think
YouTube's great for that.
And weirdly, pranks
and cats seem
to be the things
that really work.
And ironically, there is no hub.
If you want humor, you go
to College Humor or UNILAD,
or I'm sure there's
many cat websites.
But ironically, there
is no go-to site
for hidden camera stuff,
which gives me an idea, which
is what I'm doing right now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you
just give us a bit
of an insight to
your crazy process
that gave rise to so many of
those pretty exquisite seeds?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I will say--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] or was
that a collaboration somehow?
DOM JOLY: I always
say this as a joke,
but genuinely, it's kind
of probably why I predated
having walked around
your offices, the concept
of the hot desk and the
sleep pod and stuff.
When we first
started, because we
didn't know how to
come up with ideas,
we'd heard about this thing
called the writing room.
And we were trying
to be grownups.
We thought, fuck,
we're on Channel 4.
So we'd sit in a room
together and literally
stare at each other, me and
Sam, and have no ideas at all.
And then we realized
the best way
to have ideas, especially
for "Trigger Happy,"
because it was about stuff,
was just to go and do things.
So I think we blagged--
I think, yeah, Sam and I,
we went interrailing,
which was just crazy.
We got Channel 4 to pay for
us to go on a two week railway
journey around Europe.
And I think I got
two ideas from that.
[LAUGHTER]
We went up to
Scotland to play golf,
didn't get any ideas from that.
But we got arrested.
Because on the way down,
we couldn't resist.
It's a horrible joke,
and I'm not proud of it.
But we went through
this tiny little town.
And there was this sign
outside this building,
and it said, West Highland's
Dyslexic Association.
And it was so weird, and
it was like the only thing
in this village.
And so I'm not proud of this.
It's not funny.
But we did instantly get a
little sign, put it on a board,
and wrote, stop this
now but all misspelled
and just stood outside it.
And it just made us laugh.
And of course they thought we
were having a go at dyslexics,
which we weren't.
But to answer your question,
genuinely I normally
answer this really glibly
and just say, in the pub.
But genuinely, that
is what happens.
The only real difference with
something like "Trigger Happy,"
see everyone goes
out with mates,
and you get a bit pissed.
And you all have funny ideas.
But most of us,
possibly not at Google,
then wake up the next
morning and think, oh,
that was a good
night, go to work.
And I was suddenly
in the stage where
you'd wake up and think,
fuck, that was a good.
You'd wait till you were
sober to check it was good.
And then you'd ring someone up.
So for instance,
a great example,
of my favorite sketch
of ever is the snail,
just because it's kind
of perfect, really.
And it was this snail coming
up to a zebra crossing,
walking totally normally,
waiting by the zebra crossing.
Obviously it was some very
sad David Bowie music just
to make it arty.
And then everyone stops.
And then I get on the
floor, and I crawl really
slowly across the floor.
And then I get up and
walk across normally.
Now there's so many
elements to that.
I remember thinking suddenly--
because you get into the mood.
You see a milkman, you
think, [GASPS] milkman.
And I suddenly was in
the pub, and I remember.
It was a Cock & Bottle
in Notting Hill.
And I go to Sam, I go, snail.
Snail.
And the great thing
was we both realized
we're probably in the
only country in the world
where that would work.
If I went to a road in America
and started crawling across it
as a snail, I'd be run
over by a monster truck.
A redneck would get out and
sort of beat me to death.
But there is one
bit when you rewatch
that, if you ever do rewatch it,
I'm going across really slowly.
And as a cab there and
there's another one.
And as I'm crawling across,
Sam's hidden in a garden.
I suddenly realize there's a
gap, obviously, between the two
cars.
And if there was a
motorbike coming,
it wouldn't see the snail.
And so halfway across
I suddenly think, fuck.
If I'm in the middle
and a motorbike comes,
I'm going to be hit.
So sort of speed up a
bit and then slow down.
So in hindsight, I've
looked at that sketch.
And I've thought, if I
was really perfectionist,
it should have had a tiny
bit of slime coming out
the back of it.
But apart from that,
it was perfect.
And that was a classic example
of how we overplayed it.
We did it, the first
time, it worked perfectly.
And literally the first
time we ever did it,
it was on Red Cliff Gardens,
and that was the one
we used in "Trigger Happy."
So we should have
just said, right.
Let's move on.
But we were so
excited and laughing.
Sam goes, do it again.
Do it again.
And I go, yeah, all
right, I'll do it again.
So same thing happens.
I go up, crawl across, and
suddenly I'm halfway across.
I've just got past the motorbike
gap, and all I can see is feet.
And I see that one of
the cars has stopped.
There's two feet have got
out, like two pairs of feet.
And they're walking towards me.
And I was thinking,
fuck, are they
going to kick me in the face?
I couldn't move or get
out or anything like that.
And I sort of look up,
and they're two policeman.
So there's this fantastic
moment which kind of
reminded me of the
Paul Merton sketch
where he's a policeman on acid.
And I can imagine him going,
we observe the gastropod crawl
slowly across a zebra crossing.
But anyway, there's
this little standoff.
And I finally go, all right.
Like that.
And there's another
great silence.
And then a policeman, he's
quite a sweary one, just said,
I have no fucking idea
what you're fucking doing.
But if you don't fuck off now,
you'll be fucking arrested.
So I stand up, and I sprint
off going, sorry about that.
And we couldn't show
it, because we didn't
have the policeman's consent.
But that's probably my
favorite off out clip.
But basically the pub, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Dom,
thanks for coming in.
As a cricket fan,
it's a pleasure
of listening to your interview
on TMS the other day--
DOM JOLY: "Test Match Special."
None of you know that.
That is the highlight
of my entire life.
I've just had [INAUDIBLE]
said no for the third time.
This time quite
specifically, I'm
afraid he's not of our caliber.
You know, yeah, I'm not ready.
But "Test Match Special."
I was on.
Does anyone know what that is?
40 minutes with Agar.
It's like their lunchtime in
the middle of a test match.
AUDIENCE: It's my dream.
DOM JOLY: If you're a
middle class Englishman,
you've made it, basically.
Like my dad died before--
that would be the first thing
I've ever done that my dad
would go, oh, that's good.
Yeah.
So I enjoyed that.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is, if you
were offered to trade
your whole career
as it happened for maybe
Alistair Cook's, or you said
you were a bit [INAUDIBLE].
DOM JOLY: I'm more a
batsman, I think, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would you take it?
DOM JOLY: So basically
the career I've had
or internation--
AUDIENCE: Or Alistair Cook?
DOM JOLY: It depends, isn't it?
Because he might
completely fuck up.
Because I think the
only way I'd take
the swap is I'd, A, need to
be a successful cricketer.
And Cook has his
moments, doesn't he?
But also you then-- however
good you are as a cricketer,
your life's over
at 35, unless you
make the jump into commentary,
which Botham does, whatever.
And I think Cook is
to boring to do that.
I don't think he would do that.
So I'd have to be someone
that made the jump.
AUDIENCE: KP?
DOM JOLY: Oh, see, KP-- sorry,
this is a cricket thing.
KP is this Kevin
Pietersen, who's,
apart from being South
African, which is a big problem
pain for England, is
probably our greatest player,
but he's been such a wanker
that essentially the rest
of the team don't want him in.
And I think it doesn't matter.
If he's good, he should be in.
But the problem is, Piers
Morgan has literally
launched a one man
internet campaign demanding
that he should go back in.
And I'm so annoyed
by Piers Morgan
that I don't want
KP on the team.
So I think he's
probably doing it.
Yeah, I wouldn't mind being KP.
He's quite good.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So the answer's yes.
DOM JOLY: You know.
I'd like to do both.
Is that possible?
I'd like to open with
batting and then go and do
the squirrel stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe the England team mascot,
that's what I could be.
I don't think it's
going to happen anyways.
It's too late.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Dom,
thanks for very much.
It's been really fun.
DOM JOLY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Quick question,
from "Trigger Happy" days,
was there anything that
was cut by Channel 4
that you thought was brilliant
and that you could talk us
through now.
DOM JOLY: See,
that's really funny.
They didn't actually
have power of it.
I had power of final cut.
But you couldn't be
a complete wanker.
Basically, we spent all
the time in the edit.
You got the show.
And then the commissioners
would come in.
And even if it was the
most perfect program ever,
which it never was,
they wouldn't have a job
if they didn't sort
of say something.
So our plan, our
cunning plan, which
we thought was
really cool, was we'd
make the show
beautiful and great,
and then we'd always put
in something really shit
that we hated, and
it just stuck out.
And the idea was
they'll come in,
and they'll say, well, love
it, but apart from that.
And we'd sort of go, oh,
really, you don't like it?
And then look like we're
really [INAUDIBLE].
We'd be like, OK,
we'll take it out.
And I swear, we
did it three times.
And two of the three times, that
was the bit they liked best.
[LAUGHTER]
And they literally got
angry when we took it out.
So we kind of gave that up.
So they never cut anything out.
But there were a
couple of things
we did which Fergie-- two
weirdest celebs I ever did,
Fergie, Princess Fergie,
whatever her fucking name is.
I was at some weird
drinks party somewhere,
and I was trying to get people
as this celeb interviewer.
And I didn't know Fergie
was going to be there.
And I suddenly see Fergie
walking towards me.
And Sam's there with
this tiny camera.
And I'm holding a microphone.
So I'm like, fuck it,
we're going to do it.
So I go up to her, and her body
guards are-- I go, excuse me.
Can we have a chat.
She goes, yeah,
yeah, yeah, totally.
So I go, great.
I have no idea what
I'm going to do.
And I go, you're live right
now on "Good Morning, Mexico."
I think I say
something like that.
And she literally
didn't bat an eyelash.
Oh.
And so I go, tell us about all
your great work in America.
And she starts talking.
And about 10 seconds in,
I suddenly go, sorry,
Your Highness.
We've just gone for an ad break.
So if we can just
hold oppositions,
and we're back in two minutes.
And she went for it.
And I said, can no
one move at all.
We need to be in the
exactly the same position
when we come back.
So for two minutes in the
middle of this drinks party,
Fergie's just
standing like this.
And I'm like, this is fucking
the best thing I've ever done.
And then I go, and
we are live again.
Sorry, you were saying.
And then she starts
talking again.
I go, sorry, they've
lost interest.
They're gone.
And then she goes, what?
And we went outside.
And I said to Sam,
get in a cab now.
We fucking got to put this out.
And if the internet
had been around,
I'd have just uploaded
that immediately.
But I swear, I don't
know how they found out,
but by time we go back
to Charing Cross Road,
it was in Sloane Square--
it was about 40 minutes--
there was a phone call
from Mishcon de Reya--
those terrifying
solicitors-- with literally
like, you show that, and
you'll be executed, whatever.
And Channel 4 was so
terrified that they didn't
show that, which was annoying.
And the other one,
which was more odd,
was Kate Adie, who I quite like.
A lot of people I used to get
were really just an excuse
to meet them.
And I went to the
Press Club where
Kate Adie was giving
some talk on being
a foreign correspondent.
And this is the woman that's
been in Tiananmen Square
and all this sort of stuff.
And so I think, what am
I going to do, really?
Because I really like her.
I don't want to take the piss.
And so she comes out.
And I think, right.
I know what I'm going to do.
So I start talking to her.
I go, Kate Adie, you're a
huge foreign correspondent.
You've been to all
these great places.
How is it dealing
with these places?
And she starts talking.
And suddenly Sam
shouts, incoming!
And I hit the deck.
And I think that's really funny.
It's a kind of nod towards her
foreign correspondent stuff.
She just looks
literally like you've
farted in front of your mother.
She's just like,
what is going on?
And I stand up.
And then I'm so embarrassed.
I do what I always did.
I just run away, leaving
Sam to do what he always
did, to pretend that
he's a freelancer who
doesn't know what's going on.
And I have so many
recordings of Sam
on the phone to no one
going, I don't know.
I was just booked to do this,
and I'm here with Kate Adie,
and the guy ran away.
But what was surprising was Kate
Adie demanded to have the tape.
And so we got this great thing.
She said, give me that tape.
It must be erased.
And Sam went, no.
And Kate Adie goes,
give me the tape.
So I had this
recording of Kate Adie
trying to fucking censor
everything she was up against.
And again, I said
to Channel 4, this
is an amazing point about how
media kind-- they went, no.
Can't show it.
So those are the two I liked.
Very long lunch
break you got here.
Do you not do any work?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Tell the
damn squirrel story.
DOM JOLY: Oh, the squirrel.
OK, yeah, yeah.
Well, technically, it
was a sort of loose areas
to who owned all those props,
because I had them made.
So the squirrels I had made.
I used to use-- there was a shop
called Escapade in Camden Town.
And we used to think it was a
bit more punky to-- actually,
it's how we got some ideas.
We'd go to Escapade.
It was this terrible
fancy dress shop.
[BEEPING]
Is that time up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] auto.
FEMALE SPEAKER
(ON INTERCOM): May
I have your attention please?
May I have your
attention please?
DOM JOLY: Is this like
your emergency call?
I've got to go somewhere?
FEMALE SPEAKER (ON
INTERCOM): Fire alarm
in the building
has been activated.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't me.
FEMALE SPEAKER (ON INTERCOM):
is being investigated.
Please remain at your workplace
until further information.
DOM JOLY: Somebody's
freaking out in a sleep pod
right now-- like, fuck!
I can't get out.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll just
carry on with that happening.
DOM JOLY: I'll just
quickly finish this one.
So we used to go
Escapade and literally
flick through that
terrible book of costumes.
[BEEPING]
Is this you guys doing me?
It is, isn't it?
I've finally been done.
FEMALE SPEAKER
(ON INTERCOM): May
I have your attention please?
The fire alarm in the builidng--
DOM JOLY: It's killing
the vibe, I think.
FEMALE SPEAKER (ON
INTERCOM): activated.
[INAUDIBLE] this fire alert is--
DOM JOLY: The story
is in the book.
I could sell it.
Basically I got flooded.
A loss adjuster came
to my house to check
all the stuff that got flooded.
And she was American, because
so many people got flooded,
they'd flown people who'd
done Hurricane Katrina.
And I had all this
stuff in the courtyard,
and she starts noting it.
And she goes, OK, we've
got some boots, clothes,
three giant squirrels, and
one six-- what is that, sir?
I go, it's a six-foot turd. and
she goes, one six-foot turd.
And they paid up
for the whole lot.
But I don't have the
squirrels anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry, we'll
end five minutes early
with the fire alarm.
So you're going to
sign some books.
If you didn't grab a book,
there's ones on there to grab.
DOM JOLY: Where am
I doing that, here?
MALE SPEAKER: Please give Dom
a massive round of applause.